thank you for purchasing your very own
Robo dude made by dr. Wonder tainment
any attempt to operate Robo dude other
than in accordance with the product
instructions including any attempt to
open or service Robo dude is likely to
result in unpredictable behavior dr.
Wynn detainment is not liable for any
damage destruction or loss of personal
or real property or for any injury up to
and including death to the owner the
operator or others which may result from
the operation of Robo dude functions by
interacting with Robo dude in any way or
by remaining in reduce presence within 5
seconds following the completion of this
announcement you accept the terms and
conditions described in this
announcement as amended and supplemented
by dr. water table for time to time
whether before or after acceptance and
agree to hold blameless dr. wen
detainment and everyone affiliated with
dr. wonder David Frum and against all
liability or losses relating to Robo
dude dr. Leonard Damon reserves all
rights and remedies including but not
limited to intellectual property rights
in and to Robo dude robopal Robo
accessories and all patents trademarks
copyrights and other intellectual
properties embedded or in body their
name greetings robopal hello eight four
six
how are you Robo noob is functioning at
full capacity robopal that's nice
I'd just like to ask you a few questions
eight four six
where were you produced Robo new is the
intellectual property doctor wonder
Taemin all right
when were you made Robo new is the
intellectual property doctor wonder
tainment
okay head for sex
this unit is designated Robo coupe
please refer to Robo coupe as Robo dude
no please tell me about yourself eight
four six this version of Robo dude is
equipped with over a hundred new Robo
accessories and Robo features including
voice action power punch
and roboam and roboam dude will now
demonstrate robo nerves
no thank you hey person I'd like to
[Music]
at this point 8:46 began to Robo dance
which lasted 23 minutes 8:46 ignored all
questions during this time period are
you finished
how do you access new weapons 946
there's no way they could all fit inside
you robot is equipped with interior ship
a new Robo feature from dr. wonder
attainment interesting how are you
responding to my questions have you been
programmed to do so
Robo new is the intellectual property
doctor wonder daemon 8:46
tell me why you're able to respond to
questions do not intimidate